讲孩子这个事情，
首先我是第一责任人，
其他人都是给我打下手的，
我就看看这些给我打工的，
给我打下手的人有没有用处。
你老公一个月挣1万块钱，
家里所有的开支，
孩子所有的开支他都承担了，
他就是一个好助手。
我是93年的，
今年33岁，
普通大专毕业，
现在在做文员，
一个月也就3000块钱。
我是的婚未育，
遇上了人们说的那杀猪谈网恋被骗30万的那个。
不过这件事情啊，
在我这儿现在已经青州已过万层山了。
再介绍一下男方，
他是99年的，
今年刚27岁，
我比他大6岁，
他是第一次结婚，
他的原生家庭不太好，
他爸爸在他很小的时候就因为和他妈妈感情不和离家出走了，
她是被她妈妈一个人带大的，
我认为我的婆婆是一个很伟大的人，
她是外地人，
当时也就30来岁，
但是她爸走了以后，
她硬挺着一个人把孩子带大，
给他买车买房娶媳妇儿，
我从内心是很尊敬她的，
我们现在结婚三年，
有一个女儿刚十个月。
给您说一下我们的矛盾，
第一件事情是在孩子三个月大的时候，
因为我们孩子吃母乳，
她不吃奶瓶儿，
我和产后和我婆婆相处的其实不太愉快，
因为在这之前我们从来没有在一起生活过，
是因为生了孩子，
她才从老家过来和我们一起住。
那天早上我婆婆给我做的饭，
因为我在带孩子，
后来跟我去吃的时候，
我就有点不太想吃了，
我跟婆婆说，
我说妈，
我不太饿，
我吃不下要。
你吃了吧，
我就去我妹妹家了，
我是想着散散心，
中午在我妹妹家吃个饭，
中午12点的时候，
我刚吃完饭，
男方友就给我打电话，
她特别生气，
上来就问我还管不管孩子了，
我二话也没有说，
我挂了电话，
我骑着电动车就往家冲，
大概15分钟我就到家了，
一进门我还鞋都没有换呢，
我就找到了劈头盖脸的家伙，
就问我家里的饭不能吃吗？
心里有没有孩子，
不知道孩子不吃奶瓶吗？
我没有说话，
我结过孩子就去屋里喂奶了，
他就特别生气，
把那个抱枕扔到他发垫儿上，
用脚蹬了那个茶几儿，
就在外头一直嚷他妈全程就在旁边说，
你别嚷了，
别吓着孩子。
下午我就越想越生气，
我就赌气带着孩子去我妹妹家住了。
最让我心寒的是我一个人抱着孩子，
提着一个大包，
就在我们小区楼下碰见他了。
我们擦肩而过，
是因没有跟谁说话。
我在我妹妹家住了3天下，
她没有找我，
是因为她知道我在我妹妹家，
可能是觉得我安全吧。
我第三天的时候，
我回家给孩子拿尿不湿，
她在家里睡觉，
婆婆也在家。
我心里面第一件事情，
我婆婆问我孩子吗？
我说你现在知道问我孩子在哪儿了？
我抱着一个三个月大的孩子出去了三天，
你们不管不问，
现在知道问了。
我说我是个外人，
你们可以不管我，
但是孩子是你的亲孙女儿吧，
你也不管吗？
插一句话，
在这之前，
我婆婆刚做了宫颈癌的手术，
因为我婆婆没有亲人，
是我让我妈妈来医院照顾的她，
因为我们家里有孩子，
男方她是个男生，
照顾她妈妈做这种妇科手术也不太好吧，
我妈妈在医院打地铺照顾的她，
我。
就前一阵我妈刚那么伺候了你，
你现在就这么对我，
不知道你们是怎么想的。
我婆婆给我的解释是觉得当时我在气头上，
她怕说错话，
让我更生气。
后来这件事情，
我妈、
我婆婆还有我们俩一起坐在沙发上，
就把这个事情说开了，
她就答应我，
以后晚上不出去上网吧就帮我带孩子啊，
因为她岁数小，
她才27岁，
她玩心特别重，
就很喜欢上网吧打台球，
打麻将，
在我怀孕的时候，
她就一直这样，
因为她是个人创业，
不用坐班，
时间比较自由。
第二件事情，
上周五我们带孩子出去了一趟，
结果孩子的病毒感染，
他发烧了，
就是那个幼儿急诊，
当时我在上班，
我一听说孩子发烧了，
我马上就请假回家了。
第一天晚上他就出去吃饭了，
是因为工作的事情硬开，
晚上我也不知道他几点回来了，
因为他经常这样，
晚上出去我都已经习惯了，
我直接着带着孩子睡觉，
因为我听你说课题分离，
我只照顾我的孩子。
到了第二天晚上，
他又要出去，
又要吃饭，
其实我特别想阻拦，
我很想说孩子发烧了，
你别出去了，
烧的厉害的话给喂药，
我一个人喂不了，
她说发烧的话让我给他打电话，
他马上就回来，
他就还是出去了。
这个时候我给他朋友的媳妇儿，
就是他们一起去吃饭的那个人发了个微信吐槽，
就说男的真心大，
家里的孩子发烧了，
她还有心情出去吃饭喝酒，
纯属去吐槽。
后来这条微信被他朋友给他看了，
他就认为我是因为他出去吃饭而不高兴了，
从他出去了以后，
孩子就一直哭一直哭，
怎么都哄不住，
我就说你上医院。
我担心是不是小。
之类的，
我就怕耽误孩子，
这个时候我婆婆给他打电话让她回来，
他就回来了，
她回来的时候孩子就刚好好一点儿了，
不那么哭了，
那就抱过去，
他就开始哭，
结果没一会儿孩子又开始哭，
我说不了了，
马上去医院，
我就开始给孩子换衣服，
这个时候她就恼了，
她说孩子现在已经不发烧了，
你一哭就去医院，
一哭就去医院，
没完没了了。
他说我内心知道孩子没什么事儿，
但是我就太焦虑了，
我就太害怕她有什么别的情况了，
可能当妈的都这样了，
她就不去，
我说你不去，
我去，
你别管，
我就抱着孩子要出门，
我婆婆说必须让她去，
我说你别拦着我，
别耽误孩子，
她就又上上次那么扰，
她就说你就是因为我出去吃饭，
你不高兴，
怎么上医院呀，
你就是借口，
我说天地良心，
我今天纯是因为孩子生病，
她就非说不是，
我说那行，
不用解释了，
我们就抱着孩子上医院了，
在去医院的路上，
孩子睡着了，
我就说不折腾他了，
现在他睡着了，
也不哭了，
咱们就回家了，
因为那个时候我的火其实已经消了，
就转了一下，
我们就回家了，
就在路上进家，
我婆就在说，
他就说你怎么这么不懂人事儿，
抱着孩子进屋睡觉了，
他俩就在沙发上，
在客厅里，
一又说又说，
我说能不能别嚷了，
孩子睡着了，
到今天已经3天了，
我都没有跟他说话，
因为他晚上他在打呼噜，
就是我在弄孩子，
孩子发烧一会儿，
一听我不刚要睡了，
他就打呼噜，
我就非常生气，
我给了他一脚，
我让他去客厅睡了，
现在这个情况就是我婆婆和我妈都劝我为了孩子别跟他一样了，
说她岁数脚等大一点了就好了，
首先我明白最重要的是我和我孩子的生命。
我给我婆婆说。
与其让孩子有一个完整我的家，
他更需要一个快乐的妈妈，
而且我也听了您说的那个预事，
问自己三句话，
就是这件事情影不影响我的健康，
也影响我孩子的健康，
也影响我的收入，
但是我现在我没有办法调整我的心态，
我想请你帮帮我，
你现在月薪3000块钱，
你的老公现在收入怎么样啊？
他大概一个月1万左右吧，
那他钱交给你吗？
钱都在他手里，
孩子平时的这些开销，
家里面的开销，
买菜啊，
水电费啊，
物业费啊，
这些是谁在承担啊，
都是他在出娘家，
父母能对你有所帮衬呢，
没有太大的报酬，
他们就是普通的，
那你自己现在手上有多少存款呢？
大哥，
加5万，
我们那个彩礼10万块钱，
我一直存在那个没有动，
那你现在主要想问的问题是什么呢？
我也不想走到分开的地步，
现在就是想问一下怎么调整我的心态，
咱实话实说啊，
基本上女人生完孩子了之后大差不差，
你所经历的这些，
我相信直播间现在9000人的话，
可能有6000人都经历过，
就生完孩子了之后，
发现你老公并没有你想象的那么上心，
没有你想象的那么愿意为孩子付出时间和精力，
你发现婆婆也并没有刚开始承诺的这么好，
没有你想象的这么善良，
只是人间常态，
人间常态就是生完孩子了之后，
你才会看清这个世界的真相，
这个世界的真相是没有人会像你。
你一样去担心、
焦虑，
操心你的孩子，
只有你是这个世界上最担心、
最焦虑、
最操心他的人，
其他人都只是给你辅助打下手的。
既然其他人都只是给你辅助打下手的，
那我就看看这个人要用到哪些方面去。
如果你老公一个月可以挣1万块钱，
家里面所有开支都他已经承担了的话，
那他已经算是我打下手当中的员工当中的优秀员工了。
我没有骗你，
养孩子这个事情，
首先我是第一责任人，
其他人都是给我打下手的，
我就看看这些给我打工的，
给我打下手的人有没有用处。
你老公一个月挣1万块钱，
家里所有的开支，
孩子所有的开支他都承担了，
他就是一个好助手。
至于说他没有办法像你一样说半夜醒了给孩子喂奶，
孩子发烧了，
她天天陪在孩子的身边，
这是常态，
真的，
换别的也一样，
嗯，
我明白，
包括你的婆婆，
你也要把她当成助理看，
把她当成助手看，
就是你需要她做什么，
明白的说，
明确的提要求。
其实现在我跟我的关系还好，
可能那会儿我是因为产后有点抑郁吧，
通过自己的调节，
也谭家做完了就来上班了，
现在就是我婆婆在家帮我带孩子，
我每天来上班儿，
我下了班我就带孩子，
现在也挺好的，
说实话，
除开门帮他老师出去玩儿，
就他没有别的毛病，
挺顾家的，
也挺重大的，
也没有那些乱七八糟的事儿，
上下期待你不要期。
在于你老公像你一样对孩子负责任，
像你一样天天陪在孩子身边，
像你一样对孩子生病了着急，
放下这个期待，
对他现在的意思就是说，
如果我像你一样，
那就没有人去挣钱了，
嗯，
他说的也有道理，
我明白，
嗯，
其他的好像也没啥了，
像你的这个情况，
如果这个丈夫一个月挣1万块钱，
你一个月挣3000块钱，
你挣的钱基本上可以攒下来，
她挣的钱都用于家庭开销了，
养孩子了，
吃喝拉撒了，
这个搭配已经算是一个比较理想的搭配了。
对我挣的这点钱，
说实话就是给孩子买买东西，
因为家里的大事小钱吧，
可能确实都是我在管，
所以现在就是调整一下，
调整我自己，
是你就想老公婆婆都是我的左右手，
都是我的助理，
这个助理的话，
他就不可能像老板一样的关心这个公司的发展，
关心这个公司是不是赚钱，
关心这个公司的运营，
你才是老板行。
另外还有一个问题就是我们家的这个大钱基本上都在他手里了，
你说我要要过来嘛，
这个钱其实谁拿着都无所谓，
如果你能要过来就要过来，
如果要不过来也不强求，
这个事情我跟他说过，
他说一人拿着一半，
那也挺好玩，
好，
那也笔都在他那强对，
因为之前发生过这种事情，
就是他借给别人钱，
我都不知道，
他就借给人家了，
我就非常生气，
我。
那他为什么不跟我说，
就因为这个事情之后他就说，
呃，
也给你转一半家里的钱，
我就告诉你那也挺好啊，
那这样的话，
那他就是老是出去玩，
这个事情我就不要管是吗？
我明白管也管不住，
只要他想出去，
他可以第二一百个理由，
你管也管不住是反而伤了夫妻的感情和情分。
对他就跟我说，
只要我不是因为正事出去，
我要是出去玩，
第一次你不生气，
第二次你不生气，
第三次你绝对生气，
反正我听到这话我有点不高兴，
我说我已经很给你面子了，
性格问题啊，
我跟你讲啊，
姐妹啊，
其实好多男的都喜欢在外边儿吹个牛，
喝个酒，
撸个串儿，
看看美女，
在外边儿跟兄弟们争争自己的面子，
好多人都喜欢过这样的生活，
但他总有一天会明白，
一切都扯淡，
都是浮云，
跟他喝酒喝的再多的兄弟，
带他困难的时候也不会借他10万块钱，
表面上跟他再暧昧的人争到争刀争枪了，
他想要跟人家干点啥，
人家也发现你啥也没有，
你也没给我什么好处，
凭什么跟你干这个？
总有一天他会明白，
都是浮云，
都扯外面的人际关系，
90%都成，
他总有没有了队友快到这块，
让我等等，
他现在大一点，
沉稳一点，
可能就不这样了啊，
不是说他沉我了，
是他终于明白你9%就到了啊，
那我没有别的问题了，
嗯，
好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜，
嗯，
OK,
好嘞好嘞，
下见好，
我直播间应该也有男同学。
男同学，
你会发现你二十几岁到30来岁，
你交的那些朋友，
90%都蠢蠢，
没有一个靠得住的，
没有人在事业上能帮助你的，
大部分都是拖你的情绪后腿的，
大部分都是嫉妒你。
你要真过得好，
夫妻两口子齐心协力把家庭建设的很好，
盖了新房子，
你会发现你平时喝酒、
吃肉、
唱歌、
KTV按脚那些朋友的话，
没有几个人真正为你高兴的。
男同学到了35岁，
到了38岁这个坎儿，
你是不是终于意识到这个问题了？
你平时请他们喝酒，
请他们唱歌，
请他们捏脚，
请他们去那些声色犬马的场合，
全是浪费钱。
记得点赞关注哦。